la procédure de la république en
manchette une procédure ouverte très
longue
moi même
j'ai été informé de
mon investiture seulement la semaine
passée à un moment où il faut faire
campagne il faut organiser ses comptes
de campagne donc on arrive en août donc
il ya parfois des tensions est je pense
une forme d'agacement aussi sur le temps
qui se produit en même temps pour
reprendre une expression célèbre il ya
des procédures qui sont ils ouverts donc
il ya des dizaines de candidats
n'importe qui pratiquement peut
spontanément candidates et ça facilite
pas les choses à un moment où
effectivement pas les cadres du
mouvement
qui est parti dans les ministères ou l
assemblée nationale donc voilà c'est
propre à toutes les organisations
nouvelle naissante ou les choses parfois
paraître longues ou compliqué on
procédure